(host)
Imagine being the mother
to every single living thing.
What would you do
if one of your children
threatened the safety
of the others?
Would you kill or imprison
your progeny to save the world?
It's an impossible choice,
one that no mother
wants to make,
but maybe it gets easier
after the first time.
Gaia would know.
As Greek mythology's
original Mother Earth,
with the unique ability to
create life from nothing,
Gaia made the choice to
fight against her descendants
three separate times.
And in typical
Greek mythology fashion,
this feminine figure doesn't
get a very satisfying ending.
[curious instrumental music]
In art, Gaia was often
depicted as one with the land,
either a woman's torso
emerging from the soil,
or as a woman lounging
on the very ground
that she personified.
In stories, she was described
as a beautiful woman
with a buxom, motherly figure.
Hesiod called her
"wide-bosomed" in his Theogony.
But all of these terms
are just different ways
to say that Mother Earth
had a lot of curves.
Unlike the Olympian gods,
who had power
over specific domains,
Gaia's abilities
were more general.
As the personification
of Earth,
Gaia had some control
over the land and weather.
She also had
the power of prophecy
and was said to share her
predictions through dreams.
These oneiric messages were
just one of many presents
that Gaia bestowed
on her followers,
and so she was appropriately
given the epithet "Anesidora,"
which meant "spender"
or "giver of gifts."
Gaia's most important
ability, however,
was the power to create life
even without the...
usual methods.
It is because
of this very power
that the Greek pantheon
existed at all.
According to
Greek creation myths,
the universe at first
held nothing but Chaos,
a lifeless bulk of darkness
from which Gaia
spontaneously formed.
Tartarus and Eros
also sprang from Chaos,
and together with Gaia,
these three were
the Protogenoi,
Greek mythology's
most primordial deities.
With the pit of Tartarus
resting below her,
Gaia birthed Ourea to
look over the mountains
and Pontus
to care for the seas,
and earthly creatures
sprang from her skin.
In an act
that would bring about
a thousand mythological
years worth of drama,
Gaia also gave birth
to Ouranos,
a personification
of the sky
who stretched
above her in a dome.
Gaia and Ouranos produced
many powerful offspring
in the more traditional way.
Together they bore
12 Titan children,
including Rhea and Cronus,
then three giant Cyclopeses,
and three Hecatoncheires,
who were just as large as
their one-eyed brothers,
but each had 50 heads
and 100 arms.
Ouranos felt threatened
by his out-sized children
and hid them away
so deep in Gaia's own womb
that they ended up
in the pit of Tartarus,
the darkest part of Hades.
Naturally, Gaia was
upset with the situation.
Maybe Ouranos
could have gotten away
with punishing the Giants
or with forcing Gaia to
suffer painful cramps,
but certainly not both.
Gaia conspired
with her Titan children
to overthrow their father,
and the death blow
was dealt by Cronus,
who castrated Ouranos
with a sickle
made by Gaia's own hand
and threw his genitals
into the sea.
The blood from this
violent act produced Giants,
the goddess Aphrodite,
and the Furies.
With Ouranos
out of the picture,
Cronus took over as king
of the heavens.
Isn't it funny how history
tends to repeat itself?
Gaia probably
wouldn't think so,
but even a powerful earth
goddess can't outrun fate.
Gaia foresaw
that her son Cronus
would one day be
overthrown by his own son.
When he heard the prophecy,
Cronus tried to avoid it
by eating
all his newborn children
whom he sired
with his sister Rhea.
At least he learned from
his father's mistake
and didn't try to imprison
them within Gaia's belly.
But she was no more thrilled
by her son's casual cannibalism
than she was by Ouranos
playing the unfair jailer,
so Gaia conspired
with her daughter Rhea
to dethrone the cruel Cronus.
The Earth Mother
advised Rhea
to hide
her sixth-born child, Zeus,
and to give Cronus
a blanket-wrapped stone
to swallow instead.
Zeus was raised in secret
in a cave on Mount Dikti
on the island Crete.
By some accounts,
Gaia raised Zeus herself,
though others say
he was raised by nymphs.
When he was old enough,
Zeus returned to Olympus
and used a special
regurgitory elixir from Gaia
to free his brothers and
sisters from Cronus's gut.
With Gaia's help, Zeus and the
other would-be Olympian gods
overthrew the Titans and
imprisoned many of them
in Tartarus.
Angered again by
her children's confinement,
Gaia urged her Giant children
to attack the Olympians,
but they were defeated after
the gods enlisted Herakles,
for it was prophesized
that the Giants
could only be thwarted
with a mortal's help.
When that attempt failed,
Gaia lay with Tartarus
to produce a truly
terrifying offspring:
Typhus, the father
of all monsters,
who had 100
fire-breathing dragon heads.
Typhus almost defeated
the gods
but was eventually struck down
by Zeus's lightning bolt.
Not wanting to endanger
any more of her children,
Gaia accepted Zeus's role
as the ruler of Olympus.
When we talk about
ancient mythology now,
it's tempting to treat it
as a static story.
We see the end state and assume
that it was always that way.
But myths, like history,
evolve over time,
and Gaia's story is
an excellent example of that.
Most people think of Zeus
as the highest God
in Greek mythology,
but it was once Cronus
and, before him, Ouranos.
But they all got their power
and position thanks to Gaia,
who never really got to rule
over the Earth that
she was responsible for.
And even though Gaia
played a pivotal role
at the beginning
of the Greek myths,
she doesn't get any kind of
satisfying ending, good or bad.
She seems to disappear
from the myths
after Zeus's wedding to Hera,
without even the honor of
a memorable, horrific punishment
like so many
of her Titan offspring.
A modern Western lens would
blame that on the patriarchy,
saying a culture that worships
such a male-dominated pantheon
would downplay
the accomplishments
of the ultimate
maternal figure.
There's some truth in that,
but it's not the whole story.
Gaia's exclusion
from most myths
has led some researchers
to believe
that she is
a much older figure
than any of the Olympian gods.
Figurines
of motherly goddesses
have been found at many ancient
shrines associated with Gaia,
and they were
very reminiscent of statues
from neolithic
and Bronze Age times
representing the Great Mother.
Similar statues have been found
in modern-day Turkey,
Germany, and France.
Folklorist Jules Cashford
claims
that the myth of Gaia
has roots
in the ancient Indian
figure Gayatri,
who was brought to Europe
by the Mycenaeans
about 4,000 years ago.
Gaia's underwhelming presence
in mythology
could be a consequence
of conquest
or a matter of misogyny,
or maybe she just needed
a break from her kids
like any overworked mom
and lost track of time
as immortals are wont to do.
Whatever the reason
for her relative absence
from later myths,
Gaia was worshiped at
several sites across Greece,
including Athens and Delphi.
Erichthonius,
an early king of Athens,
was said to be the ill-begotten
son of Gaia by Hephaestus,
and so he decreed that Gaia
would receive sacrifices
before any other deity.
As a chthonic goddess
associated with the earth
and the underworld,
the animals sacrificed
to her had to be black.
The Oracle at Delphi
ultimately came to be connected
to the God Apollo,
but legend says
it originally
belonged to Gaia.
In the form of a tree,
Gaia breathed life into
the Sybilline stone
and gave it her power
of prophecy.
Gaia eventually renounced
her claim on the oracle stone,
and others took over its power.
Gaia was also venerated at
many of Demeter's temples,
and some scholars believe
that these two goddesses
may have once been worshiped
as a single agricultural
and fertility deity.
Gaia's origins
and her mythological fate
may be unclear to us,
but her influence on
today's culture is undeniable.
Modern Wiccans
and Pagans revere Gaia
in her role as Mother Earth.
An ecological framework called
the Gaia Hypothesis from 1979
saw the environment as
a self-sustaining system,
almost as if it were guided
by a living, nurturing hand.
In 2013, scientists launched
a telescope into space
and then ironically named it
after this primordial
Earth goddess.
In this latest incarnation,
the Gaia space Telescope
gave astronomers
the most accurate map
of stars in our galaxy
that we've ever seen,
measuring the positions
and velocities
of more than
one billion stars,
and gave me the data
that I used to get my PhD.
Whether she's serving as
the foundation and engine
of our planet's
entire ecosystem
or unveiling the mysteries
of the universe,
Gaia has always
looked out for us humans.
She made the impossible choice
to dismember
her immortal children
to save the world from
their cruelty time after time,
until she couldn't
fight anymore.
And yet, she's seen
as the prime antagonist
of Greek mythology; that is,
if she's remembered at all.
So remember Gaia, and respect
the Earth that she represents,
and for all our sakes,
stop putting
her children in jail!
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.